l'unité de soins longue durée du centre
hospitalier de plaisir a accueilli ce
mardi 5 décembre une campagne de
vaccination la première sur le
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
parmi les résidents ils étaient dix
volontaires à se faire administrer le
vaccin contre la copie 19,87 vous pousse
à des choses que ce soit juste de ces
vaccins fois profiter c'était c'était
peut-être 7 mai cet après midi on
démarre on a donc là qu signer cinq
résidants de l'unité de soins de longue
durée et juste avant cinq résidants de
l'ehpad les résidents du effectuée au
préalable un bilan de santé
une précaution pour savoir si tout
allait bien bien entendu ce vaccin
n'était pas une obligation
des consultations avec les personnes et
leurs familles avait été réalisée au
préalable
c'était une urgence et on nous a fait
cette proposition puisque on a eu la
chance je dirais d'être choisi parmi les
ehpad prioritaire c'est la seconde
opération dans le département après
celle de l'ehpad mon repos de
sartrouville le 31 décembre dernier
on imagine bien que voilà une fois passé
peut-être les premiers jours les
premières semaines certaines personnes
réticentes viendront vers la vaccination
en tout cas on va faire ce travail de
pédagogie qui nous semble essentiel
après on restera respectueux voilà des
choix individuels et j'irai qu'on fera
voilà on fera les comptes à la fin
un établissement de plus parmi les 700
programmés par la rs ile de france d'ici
à la fin du mois de janvier pour saint
quentin en yvelines
aucune autre cession n'est prévue pour
le moment